hello and welcome to this video playing
two bits
do [ __ ] again yeah that is a rematch
basically
okay so queen's gambit anti-queen scam
bit
the right word there's no d4 so it's not
a queen scan but but it feels a little
bit like it because black is playing the
typical moves
and um yeah we get an entire iqp
position bishop um to e2
and now i can take right
and should take i always have to watch
out for d4 here d4 there's knight a4
uh yeah h3
you should go to e6 this is a small
small
strategic mistake
that is a welcome uh
a trade for for white
knight e4 okay so i'm i'm just stating
the the general evaluation of a small
strategic mistake maybe
he has something direct available that
makes the whole thing okay okay so what
am i doing i can go to f3
just play this entire iqp
but i wonder about knight to f5 knight
f5
i'm attacking g7 how is he covering that
is he going for queen something crazy
like queen g5
queen g5 i can actually even take d5 so
why shouldn't that work let's see
okay so he just he just plays this f6
move that that looks
ugly like ugly chess anyway
uh knight f4
ugly is one thing the problem is maybe
it
it just is bad knight e6 right
and queen takes d5
i mean he he's playing like in the in
the game before
he he always um at the very beginning
took those very very consequential
decisions
very fast and then it was just lost
and it's the same here in this game
okay now i can go
knight e6 here
and now think about it i can check
a couple of things i can do i can check
here
and take c5 it's funny i can take f8
what is the best dome
i wonder if i have something better than
just grabbing the exchange
it's really possible um
knight f8 is queen f5 so i can do this
and then take the exchange
i mean i saw that quicker than i played
it but
i just wondered if i have something
better now he just resigns okay
yeah so that was odd you know i mean
you should probably argue that knight e4
should take a moment because it's really
an important moment in this position
um first of all here black should go
bishop e6
that is really much better then
the idea is that i mean there are a
couple of ideas but one
idea can be on a very good day there
might be a sacrificial
point to that and the other is simply to
avoid
this knight h4 idea the problem with
this is
that after the trade i'm very happy
about that trade because now my knights
are very good on the light squares after
his
bishop is off the board now i'm very
stable on e2
f3 f5 and so on the bishop is not
contesting for those squares anymore and
in this particular case there's even
this knight
to f5 idea and knight e4 is
totally not paying attention to that
and here the the one point is that it
cannot go g6
and the move that you probably would
want to play something active
like this is answered by queen d5 and
then the
knight is immediately hanging the engine
already indicates that black is more or
less lost now
but well f6 it cannot be the solution
should not be played in two seconds it
looks like it loses
so knight f4 g6 knight e6
queen d7 and here actually there is a
choice i mean you can think about
various things here here i thought
queen takes would be best
but okay ah g4 that's a very nice engine
move
the queen here has no squares that's
very nice yeah
very nice has to go here and then i'm
getting back here
so then then this is even stronger than
knight h6 because
this is of course misplacing the knight
a little bit on h6
but okay it's um it's a it's a win over
uh of an exchange for nothing this idea
with knight h4 is strategically really
interesting
and it has become um yeah more of a
known let's say concept after
a very famous game played in 1981 by
anatoly karpov in the world championship
match against court snow in
miran we can i can show you i mean i
know that game
the start of the game by heart castles
rook c1
takes e3 c5
bishop takes c4 cheeks
takes knight c6 castles
and knight h5 this is exactly how that
game went if i'm
not mistaken i think i'm right and
then after this
karpov went out uh went on to outplay
korchner in a in a classic
anti-aqp game they had b6 bishop b7
the knight coming back here and caution
i really um
we have to say that uh did play pretty
poorly this game
and lost without much of a fight but
this was a very famous example of that
knight h4 idea and if you
look at my position here it's actually
quite similar
the rook here this is exactly the same
formation
it's just the difference here that um
i'm with white i have actually two extra
tempi
i have b3 and bishop b2 extra and this
is why
this is so comfortable for white you can
play this
and get the same strategic idea just
with
extra moves and as we saw um black was
not ready for that development at all i
wonder if this is actually
something i mean it's clear that white
must be better but
yeah i can do that now it's just a good
just a good position you should go to e6
here and this is still very very
reasonable
okay guys thanks for watching